ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde allerdings
ist die heutige folge gedrängt von
dunkelheit denn ihr seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet meine lieben freunde
wir werden heute zurück in die hölle
gehen
ihr könnt jetzt schon wetten abschließt
wie auf die sterben werden zunächst
einmal nehmen wir uns unsere gold bein
schutzlose und reparieren die mit
einigen an gold denn wir benötigen ja im
der sagen gold an unserem körper müssten
generell nur alles irgendwie so ein
bisschen hier aufräumen was ich werde
mir auf jeden fall auch noch mal die
federn nehmen meinen feuerstein und auch
noch stocker ich weiß gar nicht wo ich
überlegt ob wir sind hier vorne genau
denn damit können wir uns ja hallo und
jetzt haben wir hier 22 fälle dass wir
das man nicht ausreichen
ich muss mir auch unbedingt neuen bogen
machen beziehungsweise ist auch immer
die armbrust der minister aus mit der
armbrust was ich mir auf jeden fall auch
noch machen werde sind ein bisschen
ersatz sachen was wollt ihr beiden von
mir was ich auf jeden fall auch noch
mitnehmen werde ist meine angel und ich
werde mir auch noch eine neue angel
kräften die strecke habe ich mit
inventar der mir wurde und in die
kommentare geschrieben ein joker du
musst dir das nicht so wer jetzt immer
wieder
[Musik]
person ca
ich werde mir noch eine andere
angetroffen und zwar ein ende
ich hasse diese und damit würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde sind jetzt
auch schon ganz gut ausgerüstet die
sonne ist fast schon beim nachmittag
beziehungsweise frühen abend angekommen
von daher würde ich sagen das ist ein
perfekter moment so dass wir uns jetzt
über bewegen zu unserer insel hier vorne
ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt und ich
habe auch ein bisschen schiss weil wir
nein du kommst dich mit der moment der
wahrheit
meine lieben freunde gehört schon die
sounds die werden lauter und wir bewegen
uns zurück in die hölle
schon furcht einflößen irgendwie alles
na ja wir nehmen erst mal hier vorne das
gold erz mit
dafür habe ich extra jetzt meine
glücksstadt auch mitgenommen ich habe
zum beispiel gerade aus einem block 6
goldklumpen raus bekommen und jetzt
bekomme ich
ich jetzt erst sechs raus bekommen dann
nur noch zwei allerdings bewegen wir uns
jetzt weiter wieder zurück zu unserer
festung da vorne hier vorne test ich das
jetzt auch noch mal kurz mit dem glück
bei dem quartz ich weiß nicht ob das
hier funktioniert oder ob ich die gerade
ohne tisch verbrauchern eine spitzhacke
aber quatsch ist auf jeden fall ganz
geil und daraus will ich mir auf jeden
fall in zukunft noch einen leuchtturm
bauen beziehungsweise leicht auch aus
keramik das weiß ich noch nicht so
richtig
ich werde auch erst mal hier vorne noch
so ein bisschen nett adrett mitnehmen
das brauche ich nämlich gleich um mich
bei der festung so ein bisschen der
geheimen herzinfarkt bekommen weil meine
spitzhacke kaputtgegangen ist ihr tut
mir auf jeden fall nichts weil ich einen
gold teil an habe und wir bewegen uns
jetzt wieder hier rein ich es wird
schmal direktors schwert viele meinten
zu mir luca du musst auf jeden fall
einen bogen verzaubern am besten noch
mit dieser einen verzauberung wo man
dann nur einen teil braucht und danach
quasi unendlich schießen kann
ich weiß allerdings nicht wie man diese
verzauberung bekommt ich weiß nicht in
welche richtung ich mich jetzt hier
bewegen soll und wo wir noch nicht waren
ich laufe jetzt erstmal vorne lang hier
oben doch hier hatten wir die situation
wo ich das kreuz abbauen wollte und dann
da vorne fasst trupp geschossen und es
ihr lager
was von malta nach vorne sind lohnt wo
kommen die denn her ist er irgendwo ins
ball nach vorne oder was
das quad las ich auf jeden fall jetzt
erstmal da vorne hier ist auf jeden fall
ein bisschen kloster und den wollte ich
auf jeden fall noch mitnehmen das ist
auch immer ganz geil kloster und wollte
ich auch ein wir lassen den kloster und
erstmal da vorne claas daun sein
egal
die hölle ist so ein geisteskranker
ordner wir gehen hier vorne jetzt erst
mal wieder runter und laufen hier um die
ecke rum ich weiß habe ich hier schon
war hier sind auf jeden fall auch
verkennen hier war auch eine kiste kam
ihr simples und ein goldener ross
harnisch hier vorne geht es glaube ich
nicht weiter wir können mal hier vorne
ein bisschen rum nutzern und schauen wo
man die wetterlage kommt da oben müssen
wir gegen wie hinkommen aber ich glaube
auch dass wir von da doch kommen oder
telekom von da das heißt wir könnten uns
theoretisch dort einfach mal hin bauen
dass wir vielleicht den besseren
überblick haben wenn wir uns auf der
ruine darauf befinden
ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
schiss dass ich gleich irgendwo runter
geschossen werde
wir müssen aber irgendwie vorankommen
und ich mussten lohn rothens bonner
finden und da müssen wir wahrscheinlich
rhein sind die nicht mehr
sie sieht mich ok ich muss ich muss
direkt österreich überhaupt schon hier
sind glaube ich keine fackeln nähe sind
keine fakten okay hier waren wir noch
nicht wir haben neuen ort gefunden wir
sind auf jeden fall weiter gekommen
mittlerweile schon als noch in der
letzten folge ich werde jetzt einfach
selbstbewusst durch gott oh mein gott
dass er da ist
aber ich bin ein relativ gut verzaubert
oh mein gott töte viduka töte sie machen
schon ordentlichen schaden für meine
kranke rüstung welches die vorne
irgendwo das braurecht soll die ganze
zeit wieder die fackel nur an die rechte
seite so dass wir nachher wissen wo wir
auf jeden fall lang laufen müssen und wo
wir noch nicht waren
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
geweckt die welt geweckt
so handeln wir nicht so läuft es nämlich
nicht an
[Musik]
nachdem ich überhaupt verfolgt oder
fertig bist du nämlich tot
ich bin einfach so ein profi
allerdings heißt das ja dass wir hier
noch nicht waren wenn das skelett hier
noch gechillt hat plus hier sind wir
glaube ich ihm heruntergekommene plus
dass hier vielleicht noch unentdeckte
kisten sind da es in der ruhe und jetzt
auch noch sport als ansporn okay die
können wir erst mal schön ordentlich
lohn gute farben und du bist tot
das ist alter was ist denn hier los auf
einmal kommen kommen ja ich kann hat
auch keine wasser setzte in der hölle
deswegen muss ich die ganze zeit damit
leben dass ich ab und zu brennen sagt du
bist auch tot wir warten jetzt mal ab 2
not und 24 vorn und das quartz nämlich
auch noch mit ich habe mich auch gerade
hier immer so ein bisschen in die wand
eingebaut damit wir noch so ein bisschen
mehr netto reck bekommen um uns halt
einfach ein bisschen weiter vorzubauen
ich werde jetzt auch mal ganz kurz nach
da hinten laufen das waren diese
komischen weißen blöcke wo ich mich in
der letzten folge schon gefragt habe was
das darstellt hier sehen sein da wird
man immer ein bisschen langsamer drauf
wenn man daher läuft aber was das hier
ist weiß ich nicht ich weiß noch nicht
wie ich das abbau ich nehme einfach eine
spitzhacke und wir haben
[Musik]
um gar nichts bekommen
oder doch
lochen block und daraus das aber nein
wir befinden uns hier also anscheinend
in dem bio der skelette
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier da
auch darstellen soll aber die knochen
glückliche nehme ich auf jeden fall alle
mal mit gästen doch ganz interessante
sounds die die teile machen auf jeden
fall vorne liegt auch noch eine römische
kunde das jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
was ist das hätte sie nur die zombie
villiger dahinten hier vorne haben wir
eben solche sachen auf dem boden das
zählt dieses netta gras oder irgendwie
so dass das hier ist das wollte ich mir
auf jeden fall noch mal kurz anschauen
ich glaube so ein bisschen seelen sein
sollten uns auch mal mitnehmen weil
darauf können wir schlussendlich bei uns
zu hause die netter warten so ein
bisschen drauf bepflanzen so dass die
sich ein bisschen vermehren und der halt
bessere sachen kräften bzw brauchen
können du hier vorne steht auch noch mal
eben das hier bei euch jetzt auch mal ab
das ist basalt was ich mit basalt machen
kann aber das nehme ich auch noch ein
bisschen was von mit ich nehme jetzt
auch mal ne backwards und verwandelt das
hier direkt in quarz blöcke so dass wir
ein bisschen platz im inventar anzag und
ihr auch noch hier zu blocken
damit nämlich schon mal ein bisschen
mehr platz hier vorne die fackeln kann
ich's decken die spitzhacke es auch
gleich kaputter nehme ich mir einfach
direkt mal hier noch ein bisschen nett
adrett mit was ich brauche um mich
einfach von rauen wer so ein bisschen zu
bauen die axt packe ich hier auf die 3
und wir gehen jetzt mal wieder zurück in
unsere festung rein denn ich möchte auf
jeden fall in der heutigen folge die
festung so ein bisschen durch erkunden
wir vorne haben wir nichts mehr hier
haben wir uns ja vor dem winter skelett
ein bisschen versteckt die es auf jeden
fall niemand mehr hier vorne geht's
weiter an das komische knochen biom rein
da setzt sich einfach mal ein blog in
und hier auch so dass wir wissen dass
wir dort schon waren hier vorne geht es
weiter ich weiß nicht ob wir hier
bereits waren
wir sind auf jeden fall fackeln hier
müsste der hier müsste der sein okay
danke dir also dass pornos angebliche
vorne irgendwo ich habe keine ahnung wie
ich selbst schon wieder verarscht werden
hier vorerst darauf wieder zurück ich
glaube wir sind von hier vorne gekommen
haben wir uns ja irgendwie reingebaut
auf dem dach davor dass noch 0 0
ich weiß nicht mehr von wo wir gekommen
sind habe ich hier vorne schon drin das
sieht auch ziemlich unbeleuchtet hieraus
eine wand hier vorne doch hier vorne
waren wir schon hier sind auf jeden fall
noch fackeln hier haben wir glaube ich
die dinge ins mitgenommen ja genau
und dann hier folgen die vor wollen dann
müssen wir auch schon direkt am ausgang
sein
es war auf jeden fall eine sehr
erfolgreiche höllen folge wir haben eine
menge stuff auf jeden fall mitnehmen
können wir haben ziemlich viel quartz
für unseren leuchtturm und für andere
projekte und wir haben auch eine menge
gold tatsächlich mitnehmen können plus
lohn routen und so weiter und so fort
ich werde mich jetzt zurück zu meinem
portal bewegen und dann auch noch mal um
das portal rum so ein bisschen schauen
denn ich weiss wie gerne er es möglich
die welt entdecken bei mir hier also
hier vorne sind wir bei unserem portal
angekommen in die richtung sind wir auch
schon gegangen von der richtung kamen
wir hier ist nur lava sie deswegen würde
ich jetzt das erste mal in die richtung
hier vorne gehen davon entfielen
da wollen wir auch unten in die
kommentare geschrieben luca sätze doch
einfach einen kürbis auf so dass sich
die ändern werden nicht mehr angucken
beziehungsweise dass sie dich nicht mehr
angreifen was ich ja gerade schon gesagt
habe können wir in der nächsten folge
auf jeden fall machen ich möchte
allerdings schon wieder angegriffen
ich möchte allerdings eigentlich dass
das für euch
[Musik]
was ist dass ich lebe hier vorne jetzt
einfach nur mal kurz das ganze quarz mit
und ich bin ehrlich gesagt so ein
bisschen abgeneigt da gerade darüber zu
geben weil ich weiß dass die leute mich
ja nicht mögen ich habe dort in der nähe
von denen gold abgebaut und aber der typ
ja schon nicht so happy darüber
deswegen will ich eigentlich ungern
jetzt darüber gehen da warten ja voll
viele von denen ist das vielleicht dass
das habe ich auch in den kommentaren
gelesen dass das so eine bastion ist
oder so da wird nämlich auch geschrieben
wenn du da rein gehst nicht abbauen
keine truhe öffnen die sind komplett
sauer auf dich direkt die werden mich
hundertprozentig töten wenn ich da nicht
mit krank verzauberten items rhein her
aber das sieht ja extrem krass aus
kanada zu nehmen doch darum warten auch
leute das sind auch wieder diese dummen
pumper schweine erfordert auf jeden fall
ne sandra da könnte ich das jetzt mal
test mit meinem sattel dies aber ein
bisschen zu weit weg die sache ist dass
diese bastion ja direkt bei uns in der
nähe von dem portal ist von daher würde
ich einfach sagen könnt ihr entscheiden
was ich in der typischen alltag diese
bastion befindet sich hier vorne von
daher wenn ich euch jetzt einfach mal an
katrin lasse wie ich zu meinem never
portal laufe dann seht ihr relativ
schnell wie nah die doch ist also ich
weiß nicht ob ich wirklich ein
geisteskranker glück habe hier mit der
welt die ich mir zufällig erstellt habe
aber das kann doch wirklich nicht wahr
sein also ich weiß nicht ob diese
bastionen ziemlich häufig auftauchen was
sich allerdings in den kommentaren
gelesen habe
da stand primär dass sie eigentlich
ziemlich selten
sind sogar noch seltener als festungen
allerdings befinden wir uns erst mal
wieder auf dem fest dabei war du dich
bruder
ich würde sagen ich sicher noch mal eben
schnell meine items die sache ist dass
wir in einer der nächsten folgen auf
jeden fall mal die komplette kisten
sortierung machen müssen die doch da hat
mich bin ich ganz ehrlich diese bastion
so ein bisschen getriggert ihr dürft
entscheiden was ich in der nächsten
folge minecraft mit zucker machen soll
und zwar könnt ihr euch entscheiden
zwischen erstens hundehütte schreibt
dafür einfach hundehütte unten in die
kommentare dann könnt ihr nämlich ein
kleines häuschen für balu bauen
zweitens bastion die spiegel sind noch
immer nicht gestoppt oder dritte und wir
machen eine kiste sortierung ich glaube
das will niemand haben weil das ist
extrem langweilig allerdings würde ich
an der stelle der heutigen episode
minecraft mit luca kann jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gern einen daumen
hoch unter dem video abonniert bei den
kanal weil es noch keinen teil der lose
seiten die die nächste folge minecraft
mit flug ab übermorgen um 20 uhr nicht
verpassen wollt wir sehen uns
[Musik]